warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised
everybody welcome to LED live where we
are going to expose the darkness with
the light of Christ that is what we aim
to do and we're excited to talk about
this topic here today
pornography find out on this episode of
LED live
[Music]
exposing darkness I think it's something
that he's not talked about enough we
have a special guest very excited
Michael Carducci welcome to the show
thank you and if you guys have not heard
of the coming out ministries we will put
a link in the description below
you guys got to check out this ministry
they are literally putting their finger
on the pulse of a cutting-edge topic
homosexuality transgender pornography
sexual addiction they handle quite a few
different types of topics you guys got
to check this ministry out powerful
powerful messages and really showing
that you know Christ can see us through
all of this and it's really a better
relationship with him so I'm excited to
really dive into this topic of
pornography I think that if everyone is
honest
at some point in anyone's life it's a
given time you are probably exposed to
it at some point in time and so I think
that this is a bigger problem than we
can even probably admit and we need some
some information on this so well Scotty
I just want to thank you for as a matter
of fact when I met you nine years ago it
was little like studios that actually
gave us our first break at a meeting you
actually funded the the booth for us and
that's how we began our ministry nine
years ago and what's been amazing is
that you're not afraid to address these
really difficult topics so thank you for
giving a voice to the community awesome
because I know that the reason why you
have 22,000 viewers is because you're
willing to ask the really difficult
questions also I'm really grateful so
basically as I go around talking about
the porn issue what I want to do is I
want to relate to not only the the issue
of pornography but also some practical
steps on how to find victory in that
because a lot of times people have this
tendency to think that either I'll be
delivered instantly or I'm just going to
be condemned eternally and so in my own
walk coming out of pornography addiction
I fell back into it even as an elder in
my church and so the things that worked
before didn't work again and so I needed
new tools but as I was sincerely asking
God to show me
those victories started to come but I
had to recognize that this was a process
and not an event and I think that that
actually gives people hope to to not
tell them that they have a right to
indulge in their sin but that if they
find themselves in a fallen situation
how is it that I can get back up and and
move forward and to ultimately find that
victory again and so that's what this
presentation is designed to do basically
we want out you know I wanted out of
this thing that I felt trapped in at 13
years old I discovered masturbation I
checked out a book in the library
there wasn't YouTube around back then
there was even a computer around back
then and so I self-taught myself and
back then it wasn't a Christian per se
and I didn't feel necessarily an
obligation or a commitment or or even
that I felt guilty about it but I knew
that there was something that was
holding me back from sharing what I was
indulging it but you know for me a kid
that was you know small in stature I
wasn't accepted by the boys in school
and I was beat up by my older sister we
were living in a locum housing project
in Detroit Michigan and my mom was a
single mother working two jobs time was
times were tough if my sister wasn't
beating me up and throwing me down a
flight of stairs you know I I got picked
on in school as well but the only relief
that I found was ten minutes in the
bathroom several times a day and that
became not only this escape for me but
it also became what I call my best
friend and so then all of a sudden I
come into a relationship with Jesus
Christ and I understand now that this is
wrong behavior and so okay well I want
to serve you God but this thing had
become the master of my of my life and
so to give this thing up was really
difficult and so I want to process that
a little bit this definitely I think
helps to explain where all of us are at
when we're trapped into some type of
sexual sin what's going on now is that
the enemy's onslaught towards our young
people is is exponentially much worse
than it ever was when I was a child and
so this is just an example to show about
computers and how parents have a lack of
understanding about how the enemy the
pornography industry is out to slime
your children here's a typical situation
where I think it's Billy's got a the
laptop in the room
his friends and mom is just very
ignorant about what's really going on
Joey do you have the laptop with your
friends in your bedroom and abilities
like yeah mom we're doing homework but
you can see by you know what's on the
door that they're not looking at at home
like you're not doing their homework and
and a lot of parents are really ignorant
thinking that oh you know my child is
eight or nine years old they're not even
sexual so that's not even an issue but
I'm gonna really unpack some of the ways
that the pornography industry is
targeting not only our children but also
slimming them at such a rapid rate now
now what's kind of crazy is okay this
has been going on in the home
I have little nieces that are in high
school and now that computers are being
so utilized in schooling situations they
literally sit around the desk and show
each other the latest and greatest crazy
porn thing that they have I mean the
teachers are right in the room and they
have no idea and all the kids are just
sitting around watching Mike like crazy
public school public school but I'm sure
it goes on in private school as well so
every second
according to covenant eyes thirty-three
thousand dollars is being spent on
pornography that's 11 million dollars
every hour every second twenty eight
thousand people are viewing pornography
that's 102 million people every hour
talking about the fact that pornography
doesn't care if you're a Christian or
not the average first age of Internet
exposure to porn is 11 years old 15 to
17 year-olds having viewed multiple
hard-core exposures 80% and 8 to 16 year
olds having viewed pornography online
90% and most of all doing homework there
I heard a story about how a mother
didn't want the computer in her home but
her child was starting first grade and
so the husband insisted they got a
laptop and one day as her little boy was
opening up the computer screen or the
father had forgotten to clear his
history and the boy was instantly slimed
with hardcore pornography the mother saw
that and here isn't that sad to think
that the father his own issue was what
slimed his own son as six years old
people have no idea what the internet is
they're designed to do the pornography
industries know is that the sooner that
they can expose your child to
pornography the sooner that they can
hook them they've done studies and that
they've shown that to a brain that is
fully developed about the age of 28 29
for a man 27 28 for a girl that the
first exposure to pornography for them
is repulsive but to a child who's
brandies and fully developed and
actually hooks and it creates this
addictive drive I was 10 years old when
my mother gave me my father's
pornography magazines my mom could tell
that I had some you know issues with my
own gender identity and so my mother
thought that maybe these would help me
but I remember looking at the images on
the screen and even being 58 years old
myself I still remember the names of
some of the centerfolds I also remember
the images that I was looking at but as
I was looking at those images it did
captivate me I I knew that I was looking
at something that I thought was kind of
forbidden but as I looked at those
beautiful images of the women instead of
desired to have them sexually I desired
to be like that because I thought well
if men lust after this or men desire to
have this then I must become that so
that men would desire me it wasn't
sexualized for me at that time for me it
was an identity issue but now they find
that the sooner that you can expose a
young person important it hooks them I
have a young seminary student that came
up to me and he said that his addiction
to pornography began when he was seven
years old father's a pastor mother's a
nurse they kept the computer in the
family room where everyone had access to
it and they could watch what their
children were looking at but his seven
years old he went to a Christian school
and his best friend came with a piece of
pornography that they had printed off
the computer and when he showed him that
to his friend that's what hooked them he
would set his alarm for three o'clock in
the morning every night so that he can
access the family computer in the family
room and look at pornography at seven
years old parents have absolutely no
idea what this issue is doing to their
children and they live in this fantasy
world thinking that their children don't
struggle with it and if a child has
access to anything that is unsupervised
whether it's a cell phone an iPad or a
computer your children are absolutely
defenseless pornography industry is
larger than the revenues of the top
technology
Panisse combined take Microsoft Google
Amazon eBay Yahoo Apple Netflix and
Earthling combined and pornography still
- makes more as a matter of fact
pornography mates to the average of
thirty two billion dollars Canada and
that those increases have exponentially
risen in the last few years this makes
me think of what Scotty was saying the
other day about what what money does it
take to cure the world hunger I mean it
there's plenty of free porn out there
imagine if all the money that was going
to it's towards porn could help cure
poverty around the world I mean yeah
it's just amazing you know it's our
fault that poverty exists because of
we're not caring for we're not putting
the money where it should go right we
care more about frivolous like self
indulged pleasure than we do about our
own fellow humanity that is dying yeah
that's crazy
but I don't want to minimize what you're
saying is very it's very spiritual but
we're talking about an addiction and so
it isn't an issue of whether people are
saying should I spend this dollar to
feed the hungry or or or indulge in porn
it's like I need my fix and like a
heroin addict they don't care about the
needs of other people around them when
you're an addict we're talking about an
addictive driving so I don't want to
minimize that for somebody out there
thinking that oh you know I'm less of a
Christian because I don't choose to help
the poor you really have a problem and
the reason why you're spending money on
porn is not because you're selfish and
that you want to you know reward
yourself is because you're truly
addicted okay I was talking to a young
woman two years ago who I went on a
mission trip with and she's 25 years old
beautiful young girl active in her youth
group and she was telling me that she
was addicted to pornography and
masturbation and acting out sexually
with some of the guys in her youth group
and I looked at her in shock and I said
well you know what the Bible says about
sex don't you and she said not really
because the church never talks about it
I believe that by our silence we are
giving our children permission to buy
into the things that they're hearing on
you too
things that the kids are sharing in
school and by our silence that we're
actually encouraging the the sexual
onslaught that's going on with our young
people
according to covenant I is the most
startling statistic that I have is that
only 3% of boys and 17% of girls have
never seen pornography
three percent five percent of whatever
[Music]
probably you're not 18 yeah right what
if part of our Laodicea was the fact
that we're not acknowledging the fact
that we're being slimed by sexual sin
take a look at this testimonies on
sexual behavior adultery divorce page 84
it says Satan's repetitious plots near
the close of this Earth's history Satan
will work with all his powers in the
same manner and with the same
temptations wherewith he tempted ancient
Israel just before their entering the
land of promise he will lay snares for
those who claim to keep the commandments
of God and who are almost on the borders
of the heavenly Canaan he said he will
use his powers to their utmost in order
to entrap Souls and take God's profess
people upon their weakest points what
are those weakest points those who have
not brought the lower passions into
subjection to the higher powers of their
being those who have allowed their minds
to flow in a channel of carnal
indulgence of the baser passions Satan
is determined to destroy with his
temptations to pollute their souls with
my Sencha sness as sexuality with sexual
thoughts and so now the party comes
right into your home maybe the parties
in your hand right it's that interesting
that the devil will use these devices
that we have total access to 24/7 and
and what it does is it gives us the
ability to access this pornography I
think it is amazing that that our church
is so ignorant or they are purposeful to
not talk about this issue because of
course it's a very difficult topic but
what I find is no matter where I go
around the world is that the that the
church is ready to talk about this but
the leadership because maybe it's the
fact that 62% of our ad that our
Christian pastors struggle with
pornography addiction so even on that
issue alone maybe that's why the secrecy
or just the fact that that that is part
of the layer to see is to not address a
sexual sin in the church but you know
it's awesome
is ministries like us we have enjoyed a
freedom of of having the ability to put
stuff out on YouTube I mean people can
research this topic and look and see
what kind of things are out there
we're not determined to the leadership
of the church allowing us to be able to
talk about this kind of an issue and and
so now I think we we are starting to see
that we can actually have access and
actually start to do it but more of us
need to talk about this than just one
ministry or two ministries it needs to
be across the board I mean all around
the world people are struggling with
this in my opinion this is enemy number
one in the church it's not the LGBT
issue
it's the pornography issue is number one
and sexual sin in our church the sad
reality that we've gotten to the point
where you know like you mentioned this
young lady and she's like well the
church isn't talking about it but at
some point every person who says they
become a Christian does have a
responsibility to go to the Bible first
and say what answers does the Bible have
for me if they don't find the answers in
the Bible then they shouldn't be asking
the church where those answers are but
but in reality we all have a
responsibility to go to the Bible and
search those answers out right right
because at that are at our core like
we're ansible to God first and his word
has to be paramount in the church or in
society or whatever you know it has to
be held in the highest regard it's not
then you know we got we got bigger
problems so that's that's one thing that
I would like to bring out is it first we
should be going to the Bible and looking
for those answers if we can't find them
then yeah go to somebody who's a more
knowledgeable than you but we can't just
put that on the church and say it's the
church's fault because we are
responsible too because that's right we
have access to it it's not like you know
it's locked up and a priest can
interpret it for us no we all have in
fact most of us probably have multiple
Bibles in our homes we have access it's
all
over the Internet you can go to any
Bible website and search the Word of God
for these things so it can't be on the
church at some point we have to take
ownership and take responsibility as
well Keith I'm so glad you said that
because I think that that's really where
the responsibility comes from so here
here's the struggle and and and as
parents you understand this struggle
like how much do I say to my kid that
doesn't instruct them on sexual sin but
how do I say enough to protect them from
the onslaught of what they're getting
out there if you wait until your child
is at the age of puberty to start having
these conversations you've waited too
long because again by the time they're 8
or 9 years old the kids are sharing with
them they're showing them stuff they're
already talking to them and so you've
waited too long a lot of times parents
are really wanting to restrict their
kids from listening to our presentations
because they think that their kids
haven't been exposed to anything but
doesn't it make sense that if they're
going to hear the truth
shouldn't they hear the truth from us
and who do they respect more than than
their mother or their father certainly
not the pastor or their Sabbath School
teacher and so those conversations in my
opinion absolutely need to be coming
from the mothers and the fathers and and
one more point that I want to make
especially when regarding issues like
sexuality or identity is that the
fathers really have an ultimate
responsibility to speak masculinity to
their sons so when a mother tells her
son about sex that's emasculating even
in itself and it detaches even that boy
from from the masculine identity from
his father those conversations in my
opinion really are much more affirming
when they come from the same-sex parent
exercise you know I heard a really
interesting testimony from
a mother that was talking about when is
it appropriate to actually engage in
conversation about sexuality with their
kid and she had mentioned that by you
know like you said seven eight years old
they're already starting to get curious
from friends or school or whatever the
other kids have been exposed to it and
they're starting to ask questions or
talk about it to your kid so whether you
like it or not your kid's gonna get some
information and her testimony was really
saying instead of making it this awkward
strange thing you know the kid will
naturally go and ask the kid that's
their parents about it
if it feels like it's a safe environment
and she made it a special thing she said
you know what I'll tell you about it
tonight let's have a really nice dinner
what's your favorite dinner and we'll
sit down and we'll have a discussion
about it and it was a beautiful like the
way she talked about you know God had
this special plan between a man and a
woman and she beat that information to
that child and her her take on that was
really that if you can beat the child to
proper information then when the child
hears it from a schoolmate and it's like
totally you know in the wrong context or
something really bad then the kid goes
no my mother told me that this is the
way that it is and they have a proper
context but when you play catch-up
meaning like you're now trying to
instill the proper way after someone
else has already told your kid the wrong
way it's just that much harder to to
reflect that going even further I think
this is a great opportunity to deepen
the child's trust in the Bible you know
first Timothy says that the Bible is
good for instructions in all things the
Bible isn't just about God's love
there's also some pretty interesting
stories and they're dealing with
sexuality and relationships so opening
that up to a child and saying hey this
is what the Bible says about this is
gives them that opportunity that guess I
can trust my parent but if I have
questions I could also go to the Bible
yeah hey man awesome I I want to touch
on that because there was a story that
this woman told me that just absolutely
brought me to tears I couldn't believe
just the candidness and she looked she
looked like Rebecca Donnybrook farm she
had her hair pulled back in a little
ponytail and she was wearing like this
perfect little outfit and she was a a
pastor's wife and she came up to us
after a QA for a group of pastor's wife
and she goes oh I understand everything
that you've been through and I looked at
this lady who looked like Adventist
perfection and I look at I go Mel lady
you don't have a clue what I've been
through and she started to tell us her
story and she said you know when I was a
little girl I was obsessed with wanting
to see a man naked and I was like oh but
and she went to her mother and and
because she had a good relationship with
her mother and I think this is the whole
point of what I'm getting to and what
you were talking about she went to her
mother she said mother I want to see a
man naked and her mother didn't guilt
her or shame her and she thought well I
don't really have a man to show you I
guess we could ask your father she said
no no I don't want to see father but
what she did is she answered a question
and she said well men have more muscles
than women she described it and then she
said you know they have more hair than
than women do and that seemed to suffice
her so she didn't shame her she didn't
guilt her so she still had this open
access to her mother for firm honest
information so a few years later she was
cleaning out this house somebody was
moving out and she was cleaning out this
house for somebody to move into she
opened up a cupboard door in the garage
and there was a centerfold of a naked
lumberjack leaning against a tree a man
and she ripped it down and she hid it so
that her brothers and sisters couldn't
see it well who do you think she ran to
she ran to her mother it's but I never
would have run to my mother or my father
but she did because she had that open
relationship with her mom and she pulled
in hose luck mother a naked man and her
mother didn't like Shamer and grab it
and rip it up and throw it away and say
shame on you for looking at such a
filthy thing but she'd said now look at
that
and she said wasn't i right he's got
more muscles than we do he's got more
hair you know she affirmed the biology
but then she took it to the face and she
said but look at his face what do you
what do you think he's thinking about
what's he doing she's a well he's
smiling mother well what do you
he's smiling about do you think he knows
Jesus I don't know mother said do you
think he's married I don't know do you
think that as a Christian married man
that he holds the door open for his wife
and what she did is she took it from the
biology to the spiritual and she started
to affirm that a man's value actually
has more to do with her sexuality or is
more important than that and what was so
beautiful I was sitting there with tears
coming down my face because I thought to
myself wow how much easier my life could
have been if I'd have had that open
access to my parents where I could trust
them to share everything with them and a
lot of times I hear parents say that
they tell their kids oh you know don't
think about sex and sex is a filthy
horrible thing and you start putting
these ideas in their mind and then if
they do experiment then they've gotten
this this confirmation from you that sex
is dirty it's awful it's shameful and
now you've broken off the opportunity to
have those valuable conversations to
protect your children and instead you've
made them more vulnerable and in my
opinion you've made them more of a
victim Wow then amazing yeah I really
appreciate what you said about getting
to the child before basically the world
everyone else gets to them I remember
approaching someone very important in my
life and said hey why don't you tell me
about X Y & Z and their answer to me was
oh because you didn't ask and I was so
bad it was like of course I didn't ask I
didn't know what to ask until it was
like in front of my face so that is
super important talking to your kid
about things that you know may not even
be brought up in their mind but it can
come up later on and I think it is
important to distinctly deal with those
things whether you have a male or a
female like my daughter is is nine years
old right now and she's already asking
questions and she goes to my wife and
she should naturally my son is seven
years old and as asking those kind of
questions yet
I pray that it's my job to educate him
in that area and so I think that that
also as parents you know there is a
different role that the mother and the
father play in those situations I don't
know if it's necessarily too appropriate
for me to explain the nuts and the bolts
to my daughter
but yeah definitely it and and it isn't
done in a shameful way to my daughter so
that you know now it's it's it's it's
not this like weird thing and and she's
scared of it now it's just like oh yeah
this is what happens in two married
people she's aware of it now what's so
beautiful though Scotty is talking about
this situation as you you definitely
have a role to play in your daughter's
life regarding sexuality but that's not
the specifics of what your wife is
sharing with her what's really beautiful
is that when little girls if they're in
a safe home you know what happens is as
they start going through the breeding
process it's this immutable law that the
sex it is a mystery becomes the
attraction so if they've been affirmed
my femininity the mom and they have this
good connection with their friends in
school then when puberty hits it's like
whoa what's with this sex called boys
and the only boy that they have that
some close proximity that they feel safe
with is the father and so it's very
natural for the daughter to then turn
her attentions towards her father
because he's safe and I can experiment
with that to understand more about what
boys are I think that's really powerful
and that's where you step in and you're
very valuable in your own daughter's
development because you have the
opportunity to show her what masculinity
looks like to not only make it desirable
but to also give her a pattern of what
she should be looking for and so a
father that isn't abusive that that
isn't attentive and meets those
emotional needs
then she's more likely to pick a man
that she's gonna want to be with based
on the example of the father that she
had so your time that's coming I mean
you're exempt from that well you
definitely have a it's already begun in
the way of like my my wife and I have
this kind of ongoing conversation about
simple touch you know how I as a father
touch my daughter is opening okay for
her to say oh this is how a male can can
touch me and so you have to be
consciously aware of even even
commenting on things on her body she's
going to become more aware of that so as
I'm as a male and as the father my role
to establish an affirm her
is different than my wife's but highly
important even at this stage it's so
beautiful
the way that God ordained it to have
fathers and mothers because both of
those examples are so powerful whether
you're a boy or a girl growing up Oh
question do you have a suggestion on
single-parent households if there's a
father with a daughter or a mother with
a son
those are huge challenges today
especially now that we have the
statistic that there are more single
mothers raising families than there are
dual parents and they're saying that
that statistic now can never be reversed
I remember that my family was a first
divorce on our street whereas now it's
rare to find families that are actually
intact in public schools and that is a
challenge I think that's where the
church then can step in especially if
you have a situation where there's no
masculine or male role model in the home
because then again you have little girls
that don't know how to interact with men
and they have a deficit because they
don't have that father's love so that
makes them more vulnerable to want to
act out sexually as they become older
because they're curious and they have
this emptiness to be filled and then for
boys they need an example of what
masculinity looks like that isn't a
baseball or basketball player you know
that isn't a you know a music hero or
someone like that so without those
examples both the male and the female
have great deficits going into adulthood
but if the church had a safe place and
for those single mothers you know would
it be something if we could provide like
a like a boys club or a men's club you
know for these children where you know
different men could take turns maybe
take a weekend a month to actually
affirm that child or to begin a
relationship that was safe you know that
wasn't going to abuse them or or hurt
them but instead instill in them good
principles in the show than what
masculinity really looks like a
grandfather you know maybe the the
mother's father could step in and to be
that role model for either the male or
the female child but it is a very
important position in my opinion that's
missing and I believe that the church
has an obligation and an opportunity to
affirm what Christian masculinity looks
like to a male child or to a female
child I was at a church in Florida that
they started out really small just a
men's group that began preying on on the
weekends with with the other men when
they would meet at church and in one
year's time they said it revolutionized
the entire church it was packed when I
came into it and and I mean it took an
hour for them to get around the room and
pray and everything and there was tons
of young teenage boys in the room that
were mentioning how they didn't have a
father and that this was fulfilling a
role in their life so yeah like you said
I mean that that could be huge for the
church to step in and and to start
filling some of those gaps that's
exactly what I'm talking about
I want to segue a little bit to Tim's
story and I think what's amazing is that
even though he didn't have necessarily
that open communication with his parents
um that a situation happens where he
becomes exposed and what's so amazing
about God is that he will do anything to
bring us to help it sometimes being
exposed as sometimes the only way that
God can really reach us and and I think
that Tim's story is beautiful because
even in his exposure
it's very redemptive and I want to share
this with you nobody wants to live with
a secret it torments your soul it
bothers your conscience
I created this guy that everybody loved
and I went home and didn't like myself
the effect of holding the secret that
long is that you never had the freedom
to be you I don't carry secrets anymore
[Music]
one day we were playing in a
neighborhood I grew up in a nice little
neighborhood
just playing with some friends it was a
neighbor that lived across the street
from me and he told me to come over to
his house so I came over to his house
and didn't go inside the house he said
you know come in the garage we got to
show you something so I go into the
garage and he just starts touching me
just inappropriate touching and I was 8
I didn't know what was going on
and know what he was doing but I knew it
wasn't right
I came home and I walked in the door and
my mom asked me how was my day that was
the day I became a professional liar
and I got real good at it
[Music]
a couple of days later I got called to
the garage again
and again
and again I don't know how to process
this I don't know where to begin with
this I don't know how to deal with this
all I did know is that if my dad found
out he would kill him so I had to keep
it a secret
I was literally becoming two different
people
and be the guy that could go to school
and kind of get through a day and then
there would be the guy that cannot stop
looking at pornography this is not
casual this is I can't stop I'm driven
to this thing so I had to keep it a
secret I don't want to deal with these
questions I don't have answers for this
I'm 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 I'm 19 and this
thing is still on me
[Music]
she caught me I don't know what to say I
was embarrassed I felt like a pervert I
felt completely disgusted with myself
because she's a praying woman she went
back to her room and started praying for
me he's probably the best prayer I think
my mother has ever prayed I didn't hear
it but that prayer came to God I got up
clean myself off walked down the hallway
if I made a left I'm going to go to my
room I'm never gonna talk about this
again if I make a right maybe I'd have
enough strength to go in her room and
tell her what the real situation was
because it wasn't porn that was that
wasn't the root in the situation
my mom cried I cried and
yes you wouldn't grab my younger brother
he came into Rome he said he got
molested by the same guy
then all three of us cried my dad comes
home we share what happened
my mom says that she got sexually abused
when she was six and then my dad said
that he got molested when he was five
so in one night my exposure calls to
everyone to kind of come clean and
confess
[Music]
their pain
I mean that night man
[Music]
I just can't articulate to you to
freedom my film
to be able to tell the truth to somebody
not be judged that's the most oh my god
you and to have the truth come out and
be surrounded by nothing but love
my parents their relationship with
Christ is amazing they have always been
authentic and real and how they live out
their faith I mean I just thank God that
they weren't like
the type of deep religious people that
[Music]
can't handle
pain
I was just happy that they were that
they love me that they didn't judge me
we didn't grow up in an atmosphere where
we saw any hypocrisy my parents weren't
one way at home and then another way at
church they were the same people and
they told us the right way they showed
us the right way and then they just
prayed for us
[Music]
you know when the Lord got ready for us
when he called we knew his voice because
they taught us well
I would love to tell you that as soon as
I accepted Christ into my life I put
porn down and never picked it up again
but the fact that the Lord would be
patient enough with me knowing that
didn't take me five minutes to get into
it it probably wasn't gonna take five
minutes to get out but if I just started
walking with him he just started
shedding layers of bondage and abuse on
the station oh so fast and people please
and this stuff as we begin the walk
stuff would just start falling off for
me and that he would give me
relationships when God really wants to
love you if you love you do people
and
he brought people into my life to
literally love all that crap
it's been a great walk 14 years still
walking
it's been good
so
[Music]
I don't carry secrets anymore
my name is Tim Ross and I
[Music]
what I find so beautiful is that they
say God allowed him to be exposed I mean
imagine how embarrassing that would be
to have your mother find you that way
but how beautiful it that at the end of
the night everyone had been able to
confess it they had also been through
the same experience and imagine the
healing that this family found together
what I think is really powerful is the
fact that Tim says that even though he
accepted Christ that he still struggled
he said it took more than five minutes
to get into this mess doesn't it make
sense that it would be more than five
minutes to get out that was really
comforting for me especially even
struggling again as an elder in my
church with this pornography issue like
how was I going to find this victory and
if it didn't happen instantaneously was
I doing it wrong and what that does is
it reminds me of the story in Proverbs
about that the two men the righteous man
and the wicked man you know the wicked
man falls into mischief you know but the
righteous man falls seven times so they
both fall but the difference is is that
the righteous man kept getting back up
kept getting back up and one of the
things that I encourage people is is
that seven represents not only
perfection but a process to prevention
and what that means is that all right so
seven is a perfect number but it it also
means completion and that if you're
willing to get back up each and every
time you know it doesn't give you a
license to sin but it just says if if
you've fallen get back up keep getting
back up until you work through the
process and that's what I found that in
my own relationship with Jesus Christ
that I had to keep getting back up and
again as I would get back up the Lord
would help to show me tools that I could
use to to help give me the victory over
the mine and what I think is so amazing
about God is that he doesn't expect us
to get it right perfectly and of course
he could just he could just flip a
switch or say a word and I would never
struggle with it again but what he wants
is he wants this intimacy he wants this
dependency on him and so if he gave me
immediate relief from my from my
struggle then I necessarily wouldn't
even increase my relationship with him I
would just think that I did this
wonderful thing in move on but in the
struggle of falling and getting back up
falling and getting back up I had to
learn that I had to depend on Jesus like
err like you know I thought that my
greatest curse was the fact that I spent
20 years in gay culture and that I
struggled with identity
and that every second thought that I was
having was related to to my sexuality
and I thought well that's not fair I
didn't choose to be gay and choose to be
transgender but then I realized
ultimately that it was now my greatest
gift because the Bible says that in your
weakness right my strength is made
perfect and so what I realized is that I
didn't have the luxury of having my
devotion in the morning I'm thinking
that I'm good all days that I had to to
surrender these thoughts and these
feelings on a constant basis and that if
I consciously would recognize that I was
being tempted and surrender that to God
I got the victory but he wasn't willing
to take away my right to choose and that
through that passage through that that
test with him is that I eventually
learned that I could rely on his
strength and that his strength was
greater than my abilities what was
really amazing is that that somebody
shared this with me that did you know
that if you're standing that's when
you're vulnerable to falling that you
can't fall unless you're standing and so
the idea is that get back up each and
every time no matter what it takes and
you know what then taking the Word of
God and instead of relying on my
feelings but relying on the Word of God
because the Word of God said that if I
confess my sins that he is faithful and
just not only to forgive me but to
cleanse me from all unrighteousness so
now that I'm clean because I claim his
word that doesn't mean that five minutes
later another dirty thought is going to
come into my head and so here I am at
that place again what am I going to do
with that dirty thought am I going to
indulge in it or am I going to surrender
it to God and so learning that process
takes time just like a muscle training a
muscle the more that I that I curl I
might not be able to curl more than
eight pounds but if I keep up with it
after a couple weeks I can progress to a
10 pound 1520 and eventually maybe even
a 40 pound because I've learned how to
exercise that muscle and I believe that
same with the body is the same as the
soul is through that process eventually
what used to be a tsunami that would
overtake me now is like a fly that I
could swat away as I've been learning
that process of getting back up each and
every time that I would fall and I think
there's something beautiful in that
struggle as well because
I worked on a television show one time
that would that was dealing with this
topic of being overweight and they had
surgically like removed the weight did a
bunch of like surgical things to these
people and we're like you know if that
was the end goal all it was was just to
get rid of the weight and be back to
your normal self right a magical pill
experience was it lasting everything one
of these people fell right back into it
but it was the people that spent that
time in the gym and labored and and knew
what it meant and what it took to get
that they thought twice about eating
that doughnut that second time and so
when we would go through the sinful
struggle and we understand like Tim here
you know it is a miserable place to be
in and and and he found victory in in in
opening up that and sharing light on it
and just talking about it the secrecy
you know was what really yeah the
secrecy was exposed the smoker seat was
was what was really keeping him in that
space and so sometimes it takes a lot of
courage for us to be open and honest and
come out but by shedding light on that I
think we can begin to have a road of
recovery somebody said something to me
that was really startling and they said
don't keep a secret was safe and you
know it's interesting because my fear of
exposure or my fear of sharing what I
was going through was also part of the
process that was keeping me from getting
help one of the things that happen as an
elder in my church was no way I was
going to share with my pastor that was
struggling with porn again even though I
knew that I wasn't the only one but what
I did is I started going to sa meetings
which is sex addicts anonymous yes I go
to these meetings that I at least felt
transparent because finally I'm in a
group where I can share what I'm
struggling with and even though I was
the only one struggling with same-sex
attraction all of these men were
struggling also but after a year of
going to these meetings I wasn't finding
any victory but it was at least finding
transparency how sad that in our church
culture is that we feel that we have to
guard our secrets
you know our vulnerabilities because
church isn't a safe place you know if
you're not going to get gossiped about
you might be victimized you know if you
shared what you're really going through
but I believe that God wants to change
the structure of the
Church to be more like a hospital where
we can care for individuals that are
hurting and instead of putting on our
face and packing our garbage in our
truck and coming in a church of playing
Church the church should be a place
where we can actually find healing and
End restoration can you imagine if you
actually went to the hospital with an
ailment and you were like trying to
cover it and be like you know I don't
know what's wrong with me but I'm
totally fine but you have an ailment it
would just seem silly but why do we do
that in the church right right because I
don't believe that church is safe and I
think that that's reasonable so while I
found transparency in this group one of
the things that I think was really
disturbing was that I had to say hi I'm
Mike I'm a sex addict every time I
shared a word so why would I sit there
and identify myself with the one thing
that I'm trying to leave and so identity
is important the Bible says that
whatsoever a man thinketh in his heart
that so he is so every time I said hiya
Mike I'm a sex addict I was connecting
myself to the thing that I was trying to
lead it's not a biblical principle and
while it is an AAA principle and I
understand it because if I acknowledge
that I'm a sex addict then what I'm
saying is if the victory that I'm
walking in is fragile and then I could
fall back into that at any time but the
problem is is that in Christ I'm a new
creature the old things have been passed
away behold everything is brand new and
so I want to use the story of Jacob
wrestling with Jesus all night long you
know Jacob means deceiver liar right he
was deceitful and so as Jesus is
wrestling with Jacob all night long
Jesus at one point he said to him he
says what's your name and and this is
really profound for me because Jacob
responded appropriately he said my name
is Jacob meaning I'm a deceiver I'm a
liar I'm a cheater but Jesus said no
you're not he said your name is Israel
and Israel means redeemed how beautiful
that Jesus didn't didn't require that
Jacob changes behavior before he came to
Christ he said come to me as you are and
acknowledge what you are because he said
if you confess your sins he is faithful
and just not only to forgive you your
sins but to cleanse you from all
unrighteousness so then at that point he
says your name is now redeemed
now go and walk in your new identity
isn't it beautiful and there are many
examples of that like Abram became
Abraham even before he had Isaac he said
you are you know father of many nations
he said now walk in that ident
even before it's materialized and so for
somebody like me then was transgendered
homosexual and sexually addicted that
gives me great hope because Jesus is
saying is that you're not identified by
your history or your memory he says
you're identified in me and so my
identity is now in Christ so I'm not a
porn addicted Christian I'm not a
homosexual Christian I'm a Christian
alone amen
so I want to share with you some of the
things that I struggled with as I fell
back into my porn as an elder in the
church in Child Guidance raised 445 said
those who are controlled by their
passions cannot be followers of Christ
there are too much devoted to the
service of their master the originator
of every evil to leave their corrupt
habits and choose the service of Christ
so imagine the conviction that came into
my heart as I realized that this of
course was what I was choosing and even
though I felt trapped in this in this
sin I didn't know what was going to help
me to get out of it and while I had had
the victory already I realized now that
the things that worked before weren't
working anymore
Ecclesiastes 12 14 says for God shall
bring every work into judgment with
every secret thing whether it's good or
evil and so I might be able to put on a
good face for you I might be able to
hide my sin from you but eventually I'm
gonna have to stand before a holy
righteous God and everything is going to
be revealed and that again came with
great conviction I needed something
stronger than I had had before so what I
had to start doing is I had to start
moving from my feelings into faith and
you know it's interesting because there
been several applications as we've we've
talked about how I relied on my feelings
and and one of the things that I learned
from little lights videos is that you
know let your heart decide you know
follow your heart let your heart
deciding so the heart is deceitful above
all things and desperately wicked so I
had to recognize and make a distinction
that I was letting my emotions rule not
only the sin that was in my life but
also the feelings that I would get
afterwards I have a really great
testimony of a young guy that talks
about how to address that but as I
started to see that as I would fall into
my sin the guilt the condemnation that
would come in that God didn't want me
and that my probation had closed and all
these things are recovering to me
I had to move from those feelings into
the Word of God and I had to start
claiming these promises in desire of
Ages page 340 says even the power of
demons is under the control of our
Savior and the working of evil is
overruled for good that's letting me
know that no matter how hard the enemy
attacks me and how he knocks on the door
of my heart that I have to recognize
that Savior has already won the victory
over the enemy and that he has no power
or authority anymore and that if I
recognize that the Savior has the power
that I need I have access to that if
I'll ask the greatest tool that has ever
been given to me is Philippians 2 verse
final it has such a broad application
even in its simplicity Philippians 2
verse 5 I went to a friend and I was
asking him how to find victory over the
sin and he broke this down to me for me
in such a way building verses he broke
this down for me in such a way that was
so beautiful that it's been a tool for
me ever since the only control that I
have in this verse at all is the first
word in insula which was in Christ Jesus
and so let me ask you panel you know
does Jesus want me to have his mind yes
of course he does has he already won the
victory for me to have a victorious mind
yes absolutely
the only problem is is I have to give
him permission and I have to recognize
that and how simple that concept is just
let it yeah okay the gospel has to be
pretty simple for somebody like me I
don't have a degree I don't have all
these letters after my name I'm
basically just a broken-down sinner so
when you can give me something simple a
formula that I can follow then like you
said it makes the gospel simple let me
give an example one day I was stepping
into the shower and and I'm surrounded
by soap I'd had the victory over my sin
for many months and so all of a sudden
his dirty thought comes into my mind and
of course I want it because if I didn't
want my temptation it wouldn't be a
temptation would it so we have to
acknowledge the fact that the devil
wasn't baptized when I was that the
devil is still alive and he's able to
throw these slimeballs at me there was
my history my memory of what I indulged
in for all those years
so as I'm standing there in the shower
and he throws a slime ball happy I'm
having this dirty thought but now I'm
struggling you know this this thought
and the sturdy thought is actually
demanding my attention
and the craving is strong but also now I
want to serve my Savior my Savior is
calling for my legions as well so now I
have this this decision to make inside
my mind I think what's really important
to establish is the fact that there's a
difference between temptation and sin
and what's really amazing is that just
because I'm tempted it doesn't mean that
I'm to the point of sinning but it's
what I do with that temptation this
going to make the difference and on my
own I don't have the ability to even
handle this temptation without it
slamming me so in my mind in the
bathroom there all of a sudden the Holy
Spirit spoke to me and he said might
claim the promise and in my frustration
I'm like what promise
and he said Philippians 2 verse 5 it
came into my mind so clearly and he said
give me permission to take that dirty
nasty thought in my frustration there's
this conflict going on it's like I want
to serve my Savior but I want my sin and
I'm surrounded by soap I could have it
over in just a moment and just then in
my frustration I said fine I give you
permission to take this dirty nasty
thought because if you don't I'm gonna
indulge myself what was so amazing is
that that next moment my next thought
was about baseball and I hate this ball
it's like amazing that that God gave me
the victory immediately I didn't have
time to step out of the shower and read
the Bible for two hours
I didn't have time to go on a three day
fast I needed relieve that and as just
claiming what he is already provided for
me I don't have to wait for my
deliverance my deliverance is right here
and right now if I claim the promise and
allow him to give me righteous and holy
thoughts Oh amen yes yes my favorite
person admitting and submitting this was
a process that I think is really
powerful admitting it's simony I call it
the one-two punch for the enemy the
first thing is that I have to admit that
I'm being tempted process of admitting
to yourself that you are what you're
going through and so when those thoughts
come in my head you know a lot of times
I would take those thoughts and I just
stick them in my pocket I go well I'm
not being tempted and so I came back to
Jeremiah 17:9 that the mind is deceitful
I love my sin if you didn't love your
sin it wouldn't be a temptation there so
you're always going to try to convince
yourself how you can get back to this
sinful thing and so even if I was good
like all I've been good it's been
three months since I've indulged in
pornography and so I would reward myself
by this thing that was a sin so I buy
into this lie recognizing that I will
always want my sin because sin is
desirable especially after you've
allowed it to make inroads into your
life for many years so admitting that
I'm being tempted is the first step if
I'll just admit that I'm being tempted
I'm halfway there so now there's this
dirty nasty thought comes in my head now
I've got something to do with that this
is the difference between a temptation
innocent it's what I do with this is
going to make the difference on my own I
can't touch it I can't handle it
I can't even stick it in my pocket
because eventually whether it's a day a
week or a month it's still going to have
access to me in James chapter 1 and 14
and 15 it says that when sin hid when
lust has been conceived it wins for sin
and when sin is finished it brings forth
death so people talk to me and they go
well masturbation isn't listed in the
Bible and let's just assume that when we
say porn we're talking about either
sexual acting out or masturbation and so
now that I've got this temptation
temptation isn't conceived immediately
or it's conceived immediately but it
does it isn't delivered like when a
woman is pregnant it takes nine months
before she delivers right so okay just
because I'm being tempted doesn't mean
that I'm gonna adult in this in but I've
left the door open for the enemy and so
I might stick this in my pocket and so
that enemy has access to me and so
whether it's a week or that night or
whatever the enemy is going to use this
temptation to stick his foot in the door
and have access to my mind one of the
most amazing things is if we look in the
Bible Jezebel was a very wicked sensual
queen right but she was a queen of
Israel you know so she or she had access
to God's good and holy people but there
was that moment remember when when she
was putting a whole hip stick and and
she stuck her face out the window and
she enticed the servant of the Lord to
come up and have sex with her when did
he say are there any eunuchs up there
you know throw her out and they threw
out the window and she she was mangled
mess on the ground and remember the dogs
ate her so the servant of the Lord went
in and had lunch she was hungry after
all that work but then when he came out
he realized that there were three parts
of Jezebel that the dogs wouldn't even
touch
she was so violent you remember what
they were no her hands her feet and her
skull it's
interesting because sin originates in
the mind and once we understand that
here's what I think is so profound is
that it's not an abomination the sex act
that we have what's an abomination is it
destroys our ability to relate to God on
an intimate level so the sexual thoughts
that would come into Jezebel's mind her
feet would take her to where her hands
would act out the thoughts that were in
her mind so once I got victory over what
my hands and my feet were taking me to
do I still had to struggle and realize
that sex begins and ends in the mind and
so that's how it destroys me and so what
I had to realize is that when that
temptation comes it's what I do with it
according to the mind and James chapter
one affirms that so not when when when
lust has been conceived it brings forth
sin and eventually sin brings forth
death so now that I have this temptation
the second step is submitting it to God
for deliverance
on my own I can't do this that I didn't
die on the cross for my sins I didn't
win the victory over temptation and so
if you want deliverance right now from
your sin you have to do the second part
so okay now that I've admitted my sin
now I can take that sin and I could
submit it to my higher covering he has
the ability to cancel its power and
authority over me if I'm just submitted
to him and learning this process again
is just like that muscle training that
muscle and I won't get it right
perfectly every time but if I learn the
process of admitting and submitting
admitting and submitting and as I go
through this process eventually what
used to take me over will be something
that I can manage understanding that
process as that muscle gets stronger if
I use so when men come up to me and
women come up to me talking about their
pornography addiction I tell them that
the victory is sure it's guaranteed
working the steps but the only thing
that's a variable in this equation is
your cooperation to the promises that
have already been provided no I think
it's amazing yeah for sure
Wow I guess what could also be at it as
a replacement to what they were doing as
well so now there's this I guess is void
or now they have more time on their
hands or whatever the case and idle
hands are the devil's a playground right
so and also when you were mentioning you
know your shower experience your
thoughts had to be replaced with
something else or you had to have
already had Philippines in your
mind for that to be a strength for you
to communicate with God so I think
replacing his horse my prayer also as I
gave God permission giant mind me to
help me you know cuz I could ignore his
calls but if I'm giving him permission
he's going to speak a little bit louder
when I'm under temptation and I like
what you said about replacing it's
really important because there's
dopamine that's released whenever you
masturbate or look at pornography
because this dopamine is powerful it's
like heroin in the back of your mind so
whenever you have a sexual release
whatever you're looking at your your
body takes a picture of it and says wow
that was really great let's do that
again and so whether it's a phone a
piece of paper another human being a dog
a cat or a dead person it has the same
effect because the brain takes a picture
the dopamine releases there so now if
you're if you're restricting yourself
from the dopamine that's wrong you know
by not indulging in pornography or
sensual situations it is good to replace
that dopamine with good dopamine and you
get a dopamine release whenever you
exercise you know you get dopamine
releases that are in a good and healthy
way that help to replace the drive and
the desire for the bad dopamine so I'm
really glad that you brought that out
because I think that that's really
powerful and I think it's really neat
how God actually designed our brains
because you know he made us this way
that we need to take this photograph and
we imprint on that and there's a there's
a pastor that has a series you can see
some of the stuff on YouTube laughter
your way to a better marriage if you
ever seen how he kind of describes our
brains of the man really take a picture
and then want to recreate that picture
and and so if you have you know taking
pictures of situations pornography
situations or very risky situations then
what when you come into a normal
relationship that's not what's exciting
to you because the brain is constantly
trying to recreate that imagery that
it's that it's taking those photographs
of Scott that that's really powerful
because let's talk about the dopamine
that God wants to give us and the devil
watched as we were being created in he
knows the dopamine released because if
we do it according to God's Way you're
looking at your opposite sex spouse and
you're looking
to her eyes or his eyes and then as you
have that sexual release you're taking a
picture of her or him you know how
beautiful because God wants you to
desire her to touch her to hold her to
imprint with her because in Genesis
chapter 2 it says the two shall be one
flesh when we go to first Corinthians
chapter 6 and 16 it says what don't you
know that when you have sex with a
prostitute that the two become one flesh
and so the dopamine works whether we do
it the right way or the wrong way and so
every time that we have that dopamine
release we connect ourselves to this
thing like superglue and so was designed
to to to hold us with our spouse because
you know eventually we get old we're not
so desirable looking we have kids we
have financial issues but it's that
dopamine release it's going to hold you
together to your spouse to help lock you
in I have young people that have come up
to me and they thought that pornography
was only going to be an issue until they
got married and now these young men and
young women in their early 20s are
talking about the fact that they can't
have a sexual release with their spouse
because they're so used to the
pornography that they can't have a
sexual release unless you're either
thinking about it or looking at it and
so pornography destroys our ability to
relate intimately to each other and
isn't that the abomination of God I mean
destroys the gift that I gave you to be
able to touch and to feel and experience
you know the person that I gave you to
love and one of the greatest things I
think as a human being is your need for
food and sex so you you destroy that you
know very core fundamental need that we
have as humans to have this intimate
connection I don't want to share with
you chicken his story a little bit he
talks about the fact that he was
molested at a birthday party in fifth
grade
what does I make in 12 right five and
seven yeah 12 years old so here he was
like 12 years old the kids found a
pornography magazine and they didn't
have a girl so they helped keep him down
and they ranked him many of them of the
kids that were in
in this party and so what that did is he
started spiraling out of control with
these thoughts thinking that he was
bisexual he started to experiment at it
it felt good it affirmed that for him
but then he threw Christ he found his
way out of that but he talks about some
really important things talking about
victory over sexual sin
that when I left that place I wish I was
left of the decision of who I was going
to choose was they gonna go back to the
world or was they gonna go back to or
was they gonna stay with Jesus I was
already with him so was I gonna stay
with Jesus and with freedom comes
responsibility and I was responsible for
where my feet was gonna take me I was
responsible for what was gonna fall into
my hands I was responsible for what I
was gonna think up here and what I was
gonna say from my mouth I had to say
Lady Gaga shut up I was not born this
way but I was born a son of the Most
High God I was born a revolutionist I
was born a revivalist and I had to just
allow myself to get away with the Lord
and choose him and this thought comes to
my mind this video pornographic image
you know came to my mind and I started
to think on this and play this thing in
my mind and I'm like no Jesus Jesus I
don't want this I don't want to think
this way no no no I what do I do what I
do and he said son renewing your mind
and I was like
how do I do that things like just change
your mind and it was like the Lord it
was speaking to me and teaching me
through all of this and he says renew
your mind
and so I renew my mind and I said I
don't want to think of that thought in
the name of Jesus go and I thought of a
fire truck because I renewed my mind cuz
I was I wasn't gonna entertain that
thought and so romans 12:2 says do not
be conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
so that I love this part so that you can
prove the will of God that which is
perfect good and acceptable and so I had
the choice to say Who am I gonna serve
here my flesh and my desire that wants
to keep thinking of this thought so I
can get aroused for maybe 20 minutes 30
however long it'll take or am I gonna
choose Jesus IMSA okay I don't want that
I want you I like this concept don't run
from God run to him I mean it is so true
that that we often just want to like you
know like shield ourselves from his
judgments but instead of looking at it
like that it's like no he's yours he's
your help he's your salvation you know
when you're when you're about ready to
struggle run to him know so taking that
example and then applying it for the
first time that's sin and in the world
you know what did Adam do when he said
he felt guilty and condemned and what
did you do is he he hid himself and then
I love it that how Jesus when he was
coming to Adam II he didn't like you
know condemn him and you know he just
was like hey where are you yeah you know
how like God in his tender compassion
not to expose you but instead to to
reconcile with you and to say hey where
did you go you think God didn't know
where he was do you think that Jesus
didn't know that he was hiding behind a
bush but isn't that beautiful that he
gave him the opportunity to confess
where he was and then when he did he
says well who told you you were naked I
love that he didn't condemn him what he
did is he allowed himself to confess
what
you die that beautiful and so the same
thing which says to me that if we if we
think that God hates us and that he
wants to pulled it right out from under
us it lets me know that I don't have a
full understanding of God in his love
I have a wrong picture of who God is I
like how much responsibility he's taking
it's like a partnership you know you and
God it's not that you come you you
should submit yes but then you don't
just sit there you know you have to put
in the work do your best and God will do
the rest
Wow if you fail and if you mess up or if
you feel like you did something wrong
and that Jesus wasn't pleased with you
don't allow the enemy to steal you away
for a day two days maybe a week don't
get into condemnation to where you feel
like he's too far or you messed up
automatically go back to the throne of
grace go back to the mercy seat and say
Jesus I need you and I want and I need
you to wash me with your blood and I
need you to of course be my Savior in
this situation but also be my king rule
in a reign over me so that I don't think
those thoughts anymore there's that
position where you where Jesus is no
longer just your Savior but he's also
your Lord and your king where he's the
one that calls the shots where he's the
one that guides you and instructs you
he's the one that rules and reigns over
your life and so you have to step out of
that that place of saying I always need
to be saved
and step into the place where I will
always be submitted and you can do
whatever you want but if you do mess up
I encourage that you don't allow the
enemy to have three days where you're
not spending time with the father where
you're not because that's what he wants
initially he wants to separate you from
God sin separates you from God and if
you're in sin quickly get back to the
presence of the Lord
quickly clean up and there's that place
of repentance of course there's that
place of saying I don't want to be like
that God changed me and transforming but
don't get down in the pit where he's at
rise above it and be with the Lord
that's where like when you read the
stories in Jeremiah God is always like
return unto me return unto me like you
know turn turn away from your your evil
ways and and i will quickly forgive you
know the new picture yeah i'm thing
about the prodigal sons story you know
the protocol he was like my dad doesn't
want me I'm sitting here heating with
pigs and I've done all this stuff blew
all his money they like out of
desperation you know he went back and
his dad sees him and runs to him and he
runs to his son not like oh you're back
yeah yeah ah I know right and I didn't
even understand that for myself and some
of it was based on on the father that I
had that I that I felt that I had to be
perfect for him to accept me or to love
me so of course I transitioned that or
transferred that to who my heavenly
father was as well and it was only
through a relationship with Jesus Christ
that actually broke that down for me and
I realized that Wow even while I was yet
a sinner Christ died for me meaning that
that it's Christ reaching out that that
doesn't go away and then I'm really
responding to nothing more than the
imitation already from the Holy Spirit
desire of age and not desire ages but
Christ object lessons talks about that
then while the guy was like laying in
the slop with the pigs and feeding the
pigs the thought came into his head to
go back home it wasn't thought that he
put there it was the thought from the
Holy Spirit and he was answering the
call isn't that beautiful yeah he could
have ignored that thought you know
yeah yeah so I want to share with you
yeah this one this one is amazing this
was so powerful for me because once we
fall into our sexual sin the guilt in
the condemnation I was already under the
covering of the enemy because they'd
given in to my sin I thought that I was
hearing the Holy Spirit saying that
you're pathetic
you're worthless and condemned and your
probation is closed when now I realize
that when I fell into my said that I was
actually listening to the voice of the
enemy and I think that this is really
powerful to talk about that he is a liar
he's the father of all lies we know that
you know I'm sure you've heard don't
empower the liar and the thing about
Satan is Satan is worthless and he wants
you to make you feel like you're
worthless Satan has failed God and he
wants you to feel like you felt God
Satan is sick and he wants you to be
sick Satan is dying and he's always in
fear and he wants you to be dying and
always in fear and so when I you know
what I like to encourage people is that
when you feel like you failed God or you
feel like you're worthless or you feel
like you have messed up really really
bad that's the enemy and the only power
that the enemy has is the power that you
give it so let's not empower the liar
and so and it's just simply as saying
I'm not going to think that thought this
is what God says about me
whatever he says about you that he's
ravished at one glance from your heart
or that you're his son and he's your
father or when he says he wants to abide
in you and you abide him whatever it may
be just take passages of scripture that
is truth and allowed the truth to set
you free and set you free not only from
something but into something and that's
into his heart and so I had to go again
from feelings into faith and so this is
how I felt and even before I would clean
myself up I would say to God Lord this
is how I feel I feel condemned I feel
worthless but your Word says that if I
come to you as I am worthless and
helpless throwing myself on your mercy
that you will always take me back that
you will never reject me and so I would
claim those promises and so like like
Tegan said or Keegan says that instead
of running from God I would run to him
and so it wouldn't take me days or weeks
before I come back to God I could come
back to him as I was dirtying the file
to know that he would clean me up that
was a really amazing tool for me
ministry of healing 71 it was really the
the life changer for me as a matter of
fact it's one of my favorite books and
so as I was going to the sex addicts
anonymous classes for a year after a
year I was really frustrated because
while I did have transparency I wasn't
having victory nor was anybody else in
this group I look at this book and it
says ministry of healing who wants to
read that but as I started opening up
the pages of that book it didn't talk
about my sin my problem with pornography
and masturbation but what it started
talking about was my Savior who had
already won the victory for me and even
on the first page page 17 it says that
the Savior came to restore men
completely physically spiritually and
mentally again those those three strands
of that rope and so in my margin I put a
circle and I said this is on you God you
said that you came to restore me because
I can't do it and when I started to
realize that the transition had to be
that I had to claim what had already
been done for me even am i helpless and
unworthiness
I started to find that victory again and
that book I believe has the answer for
every sin temptation every addictive
drive that we may have
and those pages are rich with the
healing that I was desperate for so
here's one of them ministry of healing
page 71 it says he is watching over you
trembling child of God are you tempted
he will deliver are you weak he will
strengthen are you ignorant he will
enlighten are you wounded he will heal
one of the things that I really realized
is that the woundedness was what was
causing me to go to my addiction the the
problem that began with pornography and
masturbation actually it wasn't even
pornography was fantasy in my mind and
masturbation at thirteen years old was
basically begun because I didn't receive
the love from My Father the rejection
that I got from the kids at school the
fact that we were living in this
horrible situation my mom's a single
mother and and acting out sexually as
well and my sister's chasing me around
with butcher knives the only relief that
I found was that time in the bathroom
alone and this became my best friend and
I want to talk about that a little bit
as well oh good good ministry of healing
also goes on it says come unto me as his
invitation whatever your anxieties in
trial my love this part he encourages us
to spread out our case before and he
said your spirit will be braced for
endurance the way will be open for you
to disentangle yourself from
embarrassment and difficulty the weaker
and more helpless you know yourself to
be the stronger you will become in his
strength whose strength his strength the
heavier your burdens the more blessed is
the rest in casting them upon the bird
bear
Wow and just processing this what I
would do is I would take these passages
and I would convert them or transcribe
them into first person because you know
what this isn't a message for you guys
it's a message for me personally and as
I did that I started to claim these
promises and the victory started to come
I have a questions yeah them I had
[Music]
or would your response be to someone who
says you know where was God why does it
always seem that God comes later Junior
your child just use the experience cuz
you were sharing it has a child you know
the lack of relationship with your
father and and how your sisters treated
you in school and all this and why do we
have to go through a lifetime of all
this trial and all this pain and then in
the end we become victorious where is
God through all those instances you know
I don't have a verbal answer but I have
a story and and whenever like somebody
comes to me and they've been molested or
abused as a child and they're angry at
God for why they allowed something like
that to happen I really didn't have an
answer but there was a man who was
molested at five years old by his
mother's boyfriend mother and father
were together the father was at work
mother was an alcoholic and she'd have
her lover come over so they'd get drunk
she'd pass out and then the lover would
actually molest his little five-year-old
boy and this little boy he remembers
being in the closet and he would look
through the slats of the closet door and
he would see that man's feet you know
his shoes and he would say you know sigh
where are you where are you sigh and so
at 35 years old these came into this
man's mind but you know his mother had
passed away when he was five his father
gave him away for a year so that he
could put his life back together but
then when he got side back here's a
little boy that six years old that had
lost his mother and his father and so
there were a lot of deep wounds that had
begun at that age not even adding on to
it the molestation from this man so now
he ends up being this this homosexual he
was also transgender he was about to
have the sex change he was living as a
woman and the Lord entered his heart and
then he eventually got married had a
child he never had this exchange now he
has an international ministry and he's
35 years old and all of a sudden all
this anger in this rage about what that
man did to him and how it derailed his
life came into his head and he got angry
and he started losing it at work and he
would get sent home and he started
yelling at his wife and kid and he
started crying out to God he said Lord
what is going on
and the Lord said what's going on what's
the matter and he said just tell me and
so I said I'm angry I'm so angry about
what that man did to me I'm so angry
about him what he took from me and he
said well what do you want me to do
about him you said I want my pound of
flesh I want to know that what happened
to me mattered and I'm not just gonna
tuck it away and pretend like it never
happened
I want justice for what was done to me
so God said well what do you want me to
do to him
you want me to publicly humiliate him
yes and he was just raging and he says
yeah you know expose him about what he
did to that five-year-old kid because
that screwed up my life and he said well
what else you know should I should I
beat him in public absolutely you know
beat him in public for what he did to me
and he just kept going on in this rage
this anger what that five-year-old boy
had to endure all these years it hadn't
been unpacked was now finally coming out
all this unforgiveness right and
eventually God said to me he said well
what if I run him out of town on a rail
absolutely everything that God said you
know so I was like that's right whatever
it takes to end this pain and what that
man did to me
and eventually he said so alright sigh
what if I nailed him to a cross and
sighs like what what are you talking
about and God was telling him he said I
paid for what that man did to you he
said I had to allow people's choices to
to run their course and I had to stand
by I was there in that closet with you
when that man abuse you I was there when
all of that thing those things happen
when your mother was killed by her by
her drunk driving and the fact that your
father sent you away the fact that you
lived as a woman for two years and and I
intervened in your life he said I had to
sit there and with my hands folded allow
sin to take its course but I paid the
price of what that man could never pay
back for you I paid that debt so that if
you accept my son as your Savior then
you can be free and to know that justice
was paid for what happened to you he
said justice was also paid for what you
took from other people and so how
beautiful that God demonstrates that
he's not asking us for just suck it up
and pretend like it never happened he
said I paid for it but I had to allow
sin to take its course and in the
process his perfect spotless son stood
in my place to pay for what I could
never pay back isn't that amazing
does that answer it does is that amazing
as well
it's a lot to take in yeah yeah yeah so
I want to talk about the dogs in the
garage what was so amazing is I asked my
church for a men's ministry and you know
what I took there was a it was gonna be
Father's Day weekend it was going to be
at a retreat you know in the woods and
and I had a speaker that was willing to
come and I presented it to my board and
one of the elders on the board took the
book and he threw it down and he pointed
right at me and he said I don't want to
be running around the woods like a bunch
of gay men and so here I was asking for
a men's ministry in my church because I
needed to know how to interact with men
right non sexually and so I didn't get
the men's ministry that I was asking for
but God gave me a men's ministry as I
started to find that victory and
ministry of healing there were men in my
church that came to me and they said
listen Mike on that gay but I struggle
with pornography and I've been married
for 35 years another man came to me he
was struggling with pornography and his
wife caught him and they had a brand-new
baby and she wanted a divorce
these men were desperate for tools but
they couldn't go to their church just
like I couldn't but they came to me
privately and you know what every
Tuesday night at six o'clock in my
living room we would open the pages of
ministry of healing and the same victory
that God gave me he was giving to them
as well what was so amazing is my friend
who was getting the victory he he was
telling me the story he said you know
Mike it was a Friday night and and and
it was cold outside and I told my kids I
said don't put the dogs in the garage
just not gonna be that cold they'll be
all right
next morning he gets up ready to go to
church and he opens up the garage door
and he let the dogs his children had let
the dogs in the garage at night they had
gotten sick something that they had
eaten got them sick
they had diarrhea and vomiting all over
the garage on that cement floor can you
imagine what that smelled like or looked
like and he thought to himself yeah I'm
ready for church I'm not gonna clean
this up so he went to church he came
back he changed his clothes and he
started to clean up all of this nasty
Phil can you imagine what it smelled
like now even after several hours right
so he's cleaning up this mess this filth
it's soaking into the cement floor the
smell is strong it's the Sabbath right
in the afternoon and as he's moving
these boxes and cleaning up all this
filth this thought came into his head
and he said you know something he said
I'm not even angry at my daughter's for
disobeying me he said this is really
their problem but I don't
after them and just then as he was
walking in the victory in his own life
the Holy Spirit spoke to him and said
you know what I don't mind cleaning up
after you either I started to realize
that he could never clean up this mess
did you ever see a child trying to
change their own diaper imagine what
that looks like and so you know if you
can if you can see the compassion of a
father that would look at a child that's
trying to clean up its own diaper and
realize that you can't do that that
that's something that I can only do for
you then can you transfer that same
thing to to a loving God that looks at
us in our filth and in our mess and says
if you'll just submit to me I can clean
you up and I can repackage you and how
beautiful for this object lesson that
you know that Jesus is the only one that
can clean up our mess and he doesn't
mind it's as a matter of fact that's his
job that's what he knows that because of
our unworthiness and our own inability
to to give the victory over our sin he
says let me do it for you imagine the
frustration of a loving parent who
recognizes that they are the only ones
that can clean you but the kid runs from
you right you know and so a kid can
actually run from their parent even
though they have a messy diaper and you
know that they're just sitting in their
mass so imagine again you know if if a
normal father can be that loving towards
their son or daughter then imagine how
God is towards us testimonies volume 4
page 349 says the victory can be gained
for nothing is impossible with God by
his assisting grace all evil temper all
human depravity may be overcome every
Christian must learn of Christ isn't
that beautiful
collecting these promises cry unto the
Lord tempted soul throw your helpless
unworthiness unpause Jesus and claim his
very promise the Lord will hear that's a
promise right there
he knows how stronger the inclinations
of the natural heart and he will help in
every time of temptation all right here
we go
and so I'd like to demonstrate this
story because it was so powerful for how
the whole Holy Spirit really spoke to me
about this issue my mother smoked for 50
years I never struggled with that I
thought it was disgusting but I remember
my mother quit smoking and after 15
years I asked my mom I said mom aren't
you really happy that you quit smoking
and she said to me she said you know
it's like I lost my best friend she said
not a day goes by that I don't think
about cigarettes and I looked at her and
I go your best friend she goes yeah
cigarettes were there and the good times
and the bad she said when your father
left me my cigarettes were there when I
go out partying with my friends my
cigarettes were there and she said each
and every day I still think about it and
I looked at it and I said but mom I said
you your best friend was killing you and
just in the Holy Spirit spoke to me and
said Mike your best friend's killing you
and I realized that because of this this
this this thing that had become my best
friend the masturbation had become my
best friend that it was really difficult
to let that go but who really wants to
be my best friend right Jesus right and
so anything that that gets in the way of
my friendship with Jesus Christ is of
course not only going to steal my life
but also not give me the best friend
that I really need and so I had to
realize that my best friend was killing
me and I had to actually recognize the
fact that this thing had to go in my
life
hatred of sin is vital to full salvation
humanly speaking no man is safe until he
has learned this to hate us and as
deeply as he formerly loved it he may
resist it he may even flee from it but
as long as there is a lingering love of
sin in the heart he is not on safe
ground it goes on to say his love of
good is vital so also his hatred of evil
it may truly be said that our capacity
for the love of the good is measured and
balanced by her capacity for hatred of
evil and so as I went to this man I that
I trusted and I finally divulged to him
as a Christian I was struggling with
masturbation still and he said you know
Mike you have to compete you have to
picture this as this big ugly beast and
it's chained to your leg
and he said and as long as you're
indulging it this beast is fat and happy
and but now you come into a relationship
with Jesus Christ and you recognize that
that this beast has to go alright so
maybe I don't indulge in it every day
maybe once a week maybe once a month but
now my my beast is is not as fat and
happy he's starving but he's still alive
and as long as his heart is beating he's
still chained to my leg I dragged him
through my relationship with Jesus
Christ and eventually he's gonna take me
out he said until you determined that
the Beast must die you'll never have
victory over your sin he said you've
gotta stab it in the heart you've got to
slit its throat and you've got to stomp
it said otherwise you'll never have
victory over your sin that was a very
valuable piece of information for me
because I had to quit kidding myself
into thinking that I could keep this
beast around
and that I had to determine that the
beast had to die and at that moment when
I determined that I wanted this out of
my life change really started to happen
because God could not go against my will
the last example that I like to give to
people is about this this men's meeting
that they had for people that struggle
with pornography and sexual addiction
and my friend went there were 32 men
they were all addicted somehow my friend
had had victory over his pornography
addiction for a while but his wife
encouraged him to go to this weekend
they had each one of them had a
counselor that was with them they spent
the whole weekend talking about
testimonies talking about tools for
overcoming and so on the very last day
what they did is they brought all 32 men
and their counselors into this maze that
they had made in the center of this huge
room 32 men and their counselors so
we're talking about 64 people in this
maze right and so the idea is that
they're all blindfolded and they have to
find their way out they can only ask
your counselor questions right so here
they are they're in this maze but they
didn't know it but they closed the maze
off there's no way out and what I
realized is that what is that is what
sexual sin does to us as we walk into it
willingly or even blindfolded and then
we find ourselves trapped and there's no
way out now they're with their
counselors and they give them 45 minutes
and they say now go find your way out
so as these men 32 men with their
counselors are fighting trying to find
their way out knocking into chairs
knocking into each other you can imagine
it was a pretty desperate situation but
of course there's no way out so my
friend is in the middle of this mix his
counselors with him and as he's going
through all of a sudden about 12 minutes
later one man got out and so he's
thinking wow one guy got out out of 32
so that meant 31 men still in this maze
and they're fighting struggling trying
to get out after a few minutes he asked
us he raises his hand as this counselor
comes over and he says what's your
question and he said is there a way out
and he said I can't answer that he
stepped away so as he's fighting in this
maze you know a few minutes later one
other guy got out two guys out of 30 -
right 30 men still in the middle of this
maze 40 minutes goes by and still nobody
nobody else has gotten out and he starts
to realize that these men are breaking
down they're starting to cry they're
sobbing because they're frustrated that
they can't find their way out and my
friend raises his hand again and this
counselor comes over and he whispers and
he says what's your question
and and the question that he had as he
said will you help me out and he said
that's the right question and he walked
him out of the circle three men out of
32 men were the only men's that got out
because even no matter what they heard
throughout that weekend they didn't
realize that only without the help of
Jesus Christ could they find victory
over the sin that they were seeking and
that's what I realize also is that God
didn't ask me to do it by myself he knew
that on my own I can't do it he's not
afraid to clean up my mess he's not
afraid to walk with me out of this thing
if I'll just reveal what my need is that
he's more than willing to take me as I
am dirty and defiled and to clean me up
and to walk this walk with me as long as
it takes until I find that victory
because at the end of my victory not
only do I have victory over my sexual
sin I now have an established intimate
relationship with my Savior which is I
believe what he's trying to restore it
in all men makes me think of that poem
where you know you see the footprints on
the sand and you know all of a sudden
the guy asked the question you know
where were you God and went there I only
see one pair of footprints and he said
God said I was carrying you you know I
mean he's willing to take our hands and
help us through these situations and it
is only a willing heart that we need and
he would do the rest
Wow Mike that was powerful and I hope
that this conversation gets continued
we're gonna keep hammering away and
putting information out Mike what are
some resources that we have yeah there's
a great series called the conquer series
and it comes with two sets of DVDs six
in each so that's 12 DVDs it also comes
with two workbooks and a journal it's an
amazing program it also talks about
accountability and restoration and it's
a totally Christian resource I find it
exceptional there's also a movie called
the heart of man which I also recommend
highly it talks about the addictive
process how it becomes an addiction but
most importantly it also talks about a
loving God that's willing to go after us
no matter how deep we've fallen into our
sin and to deliver us and bring us out
not just that but we also have a list of
counselor
that are available if you contact coming
out ministries org we're more than happy
to connect you to some of them and to
also begin conversations about how to
find victory in your sin coming out
ministries or you can find them on
Facebook you can communicate with us
we'll give you their contact information
if you guys need to know but definitely
you are not alone in this struggle you
know many many many people are battling
this and like Mike gave us some great
advice you know Christ is wanting to
help you and literally lead you out of
this maze so give him an opportunity he
will see you through and we thank you
for checking this out see you the next
one bye
[Music]